hello my name is matthias from datatab
and in this video i'd like to show you
how you can easily
calculate descriptive statistics online
with datatab
but first of all what is descriptive
statistics
at the one side you have the population
at the other side you have the sample so
the sample taken from the population
in general you don't know the whole
population
that's why you use a sample the
descriptive statistics
is now used to describe this sample
with the help of the descriptive
statistics you get a feeling
of the sample data in order to describe
the data characteristics diagrams
graphics or tables are used for example
you can use location parameters
dispersion parameters
frequency table cross tables and
diagrams
to describe this sample if you need more
information
please visit datatep.net the tutorials
and look at these sections but now we'd
like to calculate
the descriptive statistics for our own
data
to do this we go to the statistics
calculator
at datatab.net here we have a table
with exampledata if you want to
calculate the descriptive statistics
with your own data
simply click on clear table and now
you only need to copy and paste your own
data into this
in our case i will just simply use six
sample data
now we can see all the variables here
in the line let's say we want to
calculate the descriptive statistics
for with a variable age so we click
simply click
on age and now we can choose
what parameters we want to calculate
let's say we want to calculate the mean
the median the variance and
the standard deviation and now we will
get
a table with exactly these parameters
for the variable age so the mean
is 38 the median is 35
and so on and so forth further we can
also click on
salary and the variable as a table is
added with a variable salary depending
on which variables
we select we get
graphics here below so in this case we
get a box
plot for the variable h we get a line
chart which makes not
so much sense in this case and we get a
histogram
if we also select let's say gender
we get a table which gives us age
separated for the male and the female
persons in this sample further we get a
histogram
for the male and female and we get a bar
chart
which shows us the mean of the age
for male and female and we also get a
box plot if we only select
one nominal variable we can
calculate a frequency table we can get
the frequencies
the percentage and the valid percentage
and then we get the frequency table here
further we can also select place
and now we will get a cross table
with place and gender if we want
we can change the axis here
for sure you can calculate many more
descriptives descriptive statistics
but i would suggest that you simply try
it by your own
and simply select the variables and
look what you can calculate i hope you
like this video
and see you soon